mass deportations are underway for more
than 12 000 migrants in south texas they
have been living in a makeshift camp
near the border of del rio most of them
are haitians who have traveled from
south america several years ago they
came to the u.s border recently after
hearing rumors that they would be
allowed to cross their arrival in del
rio has put pressure on the biden
administration manuel bojorquez is in
del rio manuel good morning
good morning thousands are waking up yet
again living under a bridge on the other
side of this border fence which you can
see is actively being monitored by
border patrol this morning as you
mentioned the majority are from haiti
they fled their country after that 2010
earthquake and resettled in central and
south america conditions have now
brought them here to the u.s border
they're hoping to stay in this country
hoping for a better life but likely most
will be sent back to haiti
more than 300 haitians arrived back in
their home country sunday and more
deportation flights are planned this
week as the u.s government tries to
process the more than 12 thousand
migrants camped out near del rio texas
one migrant says he was in detention for
four days in the u.s four days without
brushing his teeth four days without a
shower
with this section of the u.s mexico
border closed many of the migrants tried
to cross the rio grande over the weekend
but were confronted by border patrol
agents on horseback
36 year old haitian migrant alex rossier
says if he is deported he will die in
haiti because there's no security in the
country valverde county sheriff joe
frank martinez wants the federal
government to do more it takes too long
to process
an asylum claim you know the system has
broke been broke for 40 50 years it's
used as a political football
you know
from one agenda to the next secretary of
homeland security alejandra majorca says
the u.s government is working to move
thousands of the migrants every day to
processing centers we have sent a very
clear message
early on in light of the fact that we
are in the midst of a pandemic
that the border is not open
and people should not take the perilous
journey here
in that interview secretary mallorcas
was asked whether there is a
contradiction because the u.s is
allowing afghan refugees to resettle in
this country but deporting haitians in
need the secretary said those afghan
nationals have been screened and vetted
and are being flown into the country and
in his view that is different than
simply showing up at the border gail
all right manuel thank you very much